il n'y a aucune certitude que les
nations unies tiennent compte de cette
lettre envoyée par les talibans puisque
c'est un enjeu extrêmement complexe la
décision prise par les nations unies
aura des conséquences et il y aura un
risque politique associé à cela
le fait est que personne aucun
gouvernement au monde ne reconnaît les
talibans comme autorité légitime de
l'afghanistan
même si dans la pratique ils le sont ils
contrôler l'intégralité du pays lors
domination est incontestée et cela
n'était pas arrivé depuis plus d'un demi
siècle donc ici sur le terrain les
talibans ont le pouvoir absolu
mais la question est de savoir quel
genre de message renvoyé la décision de
l'onu d'accepter un délégué des talibans
parce que si elle en accepte un cela on
verra toutes sortes de messages cela
donnera aux talibans une reconnaissance
internationale
une crédibilité qu à ce stade de
nombreux pays hésitent alors donné
se souviendra donc bien sûr que les
talibans ont récemment annoncé avoir
formé un nouveau gouvernement et malgré
les appels de la communauté
internationale à faire que ce
gouvernement soit inclusif ils ne l'ont
pas fait peut-être encouragés par le
fait qu'ils ont écrasée l'ancien régime
qu'ils ont écrasé l'opposition
opposition armée qui a affronté les
talibans après leur prise de pouvoir et
qui a été écrasée en quelques jours et
de mazda
peut-être qu'ils se sont sentis
tellement encourager qu'ils ont formées
justement ce gouvernement l'un d'eux
gens qui sont des terroristes et des
extrémistes islamistes
et si l'onu accepte les talibans comme
dirigeant légitime de l'afghanistan
cela pourrait encourager d'autres
groupes religieux militants partout dans
le monde à commettre des attaques
militaires
pourraient donc supposer que s'ils
prennent le pouvoir par la voie
militaire cette reconnaissance
internationale suivra à coup sûr d'un
autre côté refusé de reconnaître les
talibans même pas officiellement comme
dirigeant comme dirigeant légitime de
l'afghanistan est également risqué car
les talibans doivent s'engager
serait ce qu'à cause du problème de la
drogue 90% de l'héroïne dans le monde où
la grande majorité de l'héroïne et de
l'opium sont fabriqués et acheter ici en
afghanistan
vous savez les talibans ont dit qu'ils
voulaient réduire cette activité la
production de stupéfiants mais s'ils
sont exclus de la communauté
internationale ou exclue des marchés des
finances internationaux ils peuvent
penser qu'ils n'ont d'autre solution que
de continuer à exporter de la drogue
dans le monde ou peut-être même
d'exporter le terrorisme
peut-être qu'ils ne se sentiront plus
obligés de respecter leur part de
l'accord avec les états unis et l'otan
dont le but est de faire en sorte
qu'aucun terrorisme n'utilise plus
jamais l'afghanistan pour lancer des
attaques à l'échelle internationale
c'est donc une décision très risqué
l'onu un comité spécial un comité de
vérification des pouvoirs composé de la
russie des états unis de la chine ainsi
que de six autres pays il leur
appartient de décider s'il faut changer
les représentants de diverses pays
dans le passé ils ont soumis cette
question à un vote de l'assemblée
générale de l'onu afin que tout le monde
ait son mot à dire mais le discours de
l'afghanistan est prévue pour le 27
décembre ils n'auront peut-être pas
assez de temps pour prendre une décision
alors la question est encore de savoir
si la personne qui s'exprimera le 27
décembre sera un représentant des
talibans ce qui serait une véritable
bénédiction pour ce groupe religieux qui
gouverne désormais l'afghanistan dans
son intégralité ou s'il s'agira d'un
représentant de l'ancien régime dont le
président a fui le pays a démissionné
ces paroles n'auront aucune influence
sur les événements ici en afghanistan